nine months later she has a daughter
named Destiny that's a bad name I hope
you know it's a bad name that's the it's
a bad that's it's like the Toyota Tercel
why why what the [__] it's a Tercel
don't
know
[Music]
all right this one's gonna sound super
super convoluted and complicated so I'm
really sorry if it's confusing but it's
pretty heavy convoluted complicated I'm
already confused I'm ready so you got a
woman named Andrea right when she's 11
years old she meets a guy named Jason
I don't know how old this Jason guy is
but I'm assuming they're around the same
age me and Jason meet she's 11 years old
uh she says that uh she's walking home
this guy Jason starts to
um talk to her and molest her that's
what she's saying
um and then at 13 she gets pregnant holy
[__] nine months later she has a
daughter named Destiny and that Jason
dude just bounces and just disappears
okay so she's raising this Daughter by
herself okay at age 13. that's a bad
name I hope you know once Destiny turns
Destiny wants to find her biological dad
Jason
uh the grandmother decides to help
Destiny find her biological dad
Destiny ends up finding him and runs
away from home with him
turns out later after um destiny turns
Andrea we're waiting for it finds out
that Destiny and her biological dad just
say it already dude have been just say
it making sex tapes together yeah thank
you it was her Destiny you should have
been sick because I'm saying it was a
bad name bad name that that was her
Destiny it's a bad name the name is it's
a very bad name does her dad know
probably dad doesn't know why you guys
the bad name that doesn't know that
that's the daughter the dad knows
it's a bad that's it's like the Toyota
Tercel why why what the [__] a touch
sound
it's like the Honda Clarity we used to
have a Tercel Honda Clarity dude yeah
Honda Clarity is weird Chevy citation is
the worst name it's a state of being
[__] is a Tercel dude yeah what is a
Tercel dude we saw a Honda Clarity
yesterday it was the most [__] up
thing we both looked at the same time
like this is so [__] up yeah
is it the new electric thingy yeah oh
I'll show you it if you want it's what
was a big old butt right the butt sticks
out hella far but it has this weird
thing over the wheel looks like [__]
people know what Tundra is I don't know
why you guys are so judgmental about a
love story so what happens is um they
end up getting found in Mexico together
and they got arrested
um and are and are currently in jail
like what I'm just [__] my [__]
daughter no I'm not [__] my daughter
because I didn't raise her Jesus I'm not
excited right now yeah they're uh yeah
they're they're literally in jail
because you can't do this
I'm just [__] with Destiny what's
wrong with that
that's very good Bart I like that one
wait next coat what can you okay that no
never mind oh go ask a question
I'm sure it's self-implicating incest is
illegal in Mexico oh whoa whoa whoa
what's going on there I was just
wondering about a date with Destiny yeah
that's not bad is there they have mug
shots yeah
yeah is it called incesto so that's um
that's the original mom Andrea right
there right here that's the daughter
Destiny and that's Jason oh they look
very similar Jason likes himself quite a
bit oh my God bro she almost looks like
she was The Last of Us kinda huh so that
father and daughter they're making like
um sex tapes like and selling them I
don't know if that means but they're
calling them father-daughter sex tape
like like that's their angle huh yeah I
guess that's their name that's actually
real that's got to be a good angle but
let me let me ask you guys this you know
as a as a purist we're all very creative
and artistic right like do you think
when they see these porn hubs and it's
all like
this is not the real [__] we are the
real [__] and then they're faking it
yeah and they're like they're like these
snobby [__]
actually a true father-daughter [__]
yeah they're like look here's the
23andMe here's the last
thing here's my birth certificate here's
my daughter's birth certificate yeah
okay now we're gonna [__] the crazy
thing too is that um even though Andrea
was trying to like go to the cops and
like say that this was happening to her
daughter they were like we can't do
anything because she's 18. they're like
she's an adult why yeah that's what she
said and she wants it that's just
they're like lady that's disgusting but
[__] there's nothing we can do but in
Mexico they're like oh [__] that [__]
man that's [__] incestual that's just
illegal here I guess once they were able
to find the material they were making
then they could conclude that like oh
that is illegal but incestual porn well
yeah you can't do that that's that's
illegal but
the fact that the daughter was with the
um the father that's not illegal because
she was saying oh he's forcing her to do
these things he's forcing her she's like
brainwashing her and they're like well
if she wants to be with him she can be
with him you know what's but they can't
make that they can't make this material
what if they didn't study the law and
then they're like we're gonna Mexico the
[__] all we want and then they go there
and actually illegal Mexico and then
they get caught there they should have
stayed and [__] wherever the [__]
they were so you guys did 23 and me
right yeah I did not I did I did I did
you guys have any white in you or
anything like that nope not up so has
anybody else turned on by this a little
bit
[Laughter]
the closest I am is
I have uh I have a lot of Neanderthal in
me oh that's cool it's like uh over over
90 more than the more than the public
wait you're 90
no but like in in general humans don't
have that much Neanderthal DNA but then
I'm 90 more than the population like an
underdeveloped human being no
a lot of Europeans have neanderthals I
think that your mom just drank while she
was pregnant
it's not like having Down syndrome it's
fetal alcohol syndrome isn't the
question if you're a little turned on by
this no if you're a little white yeah a
lot of white people have Neanderthal DNA
that's right in the comments
yeah most people most white people do a
lot of white people and in neanderthals
out there
oh my God that's funny bro where do you
find these stories how does that happen
to you I looked my 23andMe recently and
I was just looking at all the different
things that I might be susceptible to
and I found out that I have a lot of
yeah and then a lot of Asians actually
don't have that much so I was like
that's interesting I have you're special
dude yeah or it could be a Japanese
population thing because there's more um
there's like weird indigenous stuff
there I got no Neanderthal I mean bro
you mad about it you have it all [__]
quick quick blast yeah
quick blast 23andMe it was one of his
widgets yeah
bro in a second I gotta get the app it
was one of his widgets how'd you get it
so fast are you are you slow twitch
because it says a lot of South well
again you're not Southeast Asian I'm
slow twitch I'm very slow twitch muscle
what does that mean I have and okay I'm
checking out the Indiana thoughts okay
so I'll tell you like even muscle fiber
like if you're more fast twitch if
you're slow twitch which sports you're
have a higher oh [__] you're being
better check this out your muscle fiber
type read this
hey necklace you have more Neanderthal
DNA than 99 of other customers what's up
bro 99
neanderthals or prehistoric humans I
have two percent I have less than two
more than two percent you can't even
call yourself
he's a true yeah you're like the The
Stepfather daughter porn on PornHub
that's not real that's a lot of
Neanderthal 99 that was [__] caveman
dude you think that's why you're so good
at fighting Nick's IQ is probably in the
toilet huh
my mom was drinking [__] homemade
whiskey dude yeah I did so back to the
question are you a little bit turned on
by this yeah are you turned on you know
what unfortunately as a person with a
hot sister though I think he's dreamy no
dude wait who's the person Nick who's
dreaming all three of you guys his
sisters is hot apparently that's right
but it's forbidden fruit because she's
lesbian that's what makes it hard
she's like a seven but being a lesbian
makes her a nine I have a straight
sister too bro
but we're only focused on the more uh
football jersey The Forbidden one oh
okay yeah yeah she uh she has a short
haircut and wears football jerseys all
the time with shorts that go to her
ankles my sister's more tits than Nick's
sisters more ass
laughs
oh my god dude we still have a couple
more minutes on this video I think we
hiked it all the way yeah it is crazy
how how
shitty some people's lives are because
she didn't even have a choice she's like
[__] what 11 met the dude and then
gave birth when she was 13. it's kind of
sad the mom yeah and then it's like
both women are getting exploited by the
same dude and how many other girls did
this guy [__] destroy the lives of
Honestly though like that's a victim
blame but that daughter sought this
[__] piece of junk out why well she
wants to know her daddy I don't think
she was like hey let's let's [__] hard
I don't feel sorry for the daughter but
I do go the dad's a [__] scumbag
that's what I mean right the guys are
funny but even for the daughter to like
look at her mom's life and to be able to
try and process because she's already
older than what her mom was when her mom
became a mom yeah right it's like wait a
minute so this guy molested you when
you're 11 made you pregnant at 13 then
bounce when you and you still want to
know it's like I really want to go find
him but that's why I don't I don't feel
sorry for her at all but the mom though
there's a there's a primal need to want
to know your Origins and who birthed you
but like even if you're a scum know them
versus like I want to [__] hard like
that that escalated quick it makes sense
yeah let's make pornos out of it by
fleeing the country that's a whole other
thing right like that's a that's another
step of you know [__] hard it's like
going up like it takes a lot of prep to
film stuff that's why it's a weird thing
that she's saying that the dude is
taking advantage of her daughter but the
police are like well your daughter's of
age the dude is a scumbag that's that's
a 100 I bet he's got some tricks I bet
he's got some tricks to coerce this
young lady it's like let's say this
guy's railing and making babies with
like 10 girls right and they go guys are
[__] trash and I'm like no
I know dude this guy's a scumbag I'm
glad they hate this [__] we don't like
this stuff but send me send me this
video
only the white guy though and the
Neanderthals in the room
it's genetic you can't it's just it's
genetic
I have to like it
[Music]